While it isn't stated outright, "Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever" heavily implies that
M'Baku gained a high-ranking position
in the African nation. The actor
who plays him all but confirmed it.
Wakanda undergoes a lot of changes
during "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever."
"This movie is so much."
The film begins with the death of
King T'Challa, who was played by
the late Chadwick Boseman. M'Baku becomes
an advisor to the Wakandan royal family,
helping Shuri as she grieves. T'Challa and
Shuri's mother, Queen Ramonda, takes the throne.
After a fight in Boston that
leads to Shuri being kidnapped,
Ramonda takes away Okoye's title as General
of the Dora Milaje, claiming that Okoye is
failing in her role as protector. Queen Ramonda
is then killed when Talokan attacks Wakanda with
a flood. As Shuri struggles with the sudden
deaths of her brother and mother, she decides
to step into the suit of the Black Panther,
becoming the ultimate protector of Wakanda.
It's a lot to pack into two hours and 41
minutes, but the movie still has room for
more storylines. As the film continues to
add depth to the characters established
in 2018's "Black Panther," several
new characters also into the fold.
That includes MIT student — and future Ironheart
— Riri Williams and Namor, who rules over Talokan.
By the end of the movie, it seems that
Shuri is now the official leader of Wakanda,
but Winston Duke, who plays
M'Baku, begs to differ.
New cutaway, M’baku chanting.
End after mask is removed
Shuri
may be the new Black Panther, but Duke
has confirmed that M'Baku is, in fact,
the new king of Wakanda. He recently told Esquire,
"Yeah, it's kind of cool, though, being revealed
as the king of Wakanda at the end of the movie."
M'Baku was first introduced in "Black Panther"
as the leader of the Jabari Tribe. He challenges
T'Challa for the throne of Wakanda following
the death of T'Challa's father T'Chaka.
"I, M'Baku, leader of the Jabari--"
"I accept your challenge."
T'Challa, who had already taken on the
role of Black Panther years earlier,
defeats M'Baku, replacing his father as king.
There is a callback to this duel
at the end of "Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever." The ceremony to
make Shuri queen of Wakanda has begun,
but Shuri isn't here: she has decided to visit
Nakia in Haiti, where Shuri meets her nephew,
Nakia and T'Challa's son. When Shuri
doesn't arrive at Warrior Falls,
the title of king instead appears to be up for
M'Baku to claim, with no visible challengers.
Shuri's absence at the ceremony could be
interpreted as a forfeit, making M'Baku
the new king of Wakanda. Regardless,
Duke called the moment huge, saying,
"Whatever that entails,
that's gonna be a fun one."
So what does it take to be king of
Wakanda? According to Winston Duke,
it's all about putting the
people first. He told Esquire,
"I think any power of authority and leadership
is gonna be defined by their willingness to think
of the greater good for everyone, instead
of their own personal needs and agendas."
Duke noted that there are still plenty
more stories to tell in this part of
the MCU. Of course, that could include his
potential reign in Wakanda. While Duke said
he would love to see at least four
more movies in the Black Panther saga,
he also brought up the idea of a possible spin-off
for his character and the Jabari Tribe. He said,
"They are an entity unto themselves in
the mountains. [...] And I feel like
if you got a spin-off, that we get
to learn what things mean, and why,
and why they're special, and dive into that
culture, it would be something really special."